The first location is the Ministry of Communication and Information.
It's a very colorful building and used to be the police station.
The second location on our photo tour here in Singapore is little India.
There're so many colorful houses and my favorite one...
...is this one behind me.
The third stop for our photos today is here at the Haji Lane.
I think that's how you pronounce it at the Arab district.
There's lots of shops and cafes, super colorful.
The fourth place is still within the Kampong  glam area...
...which is the Arab neighborhood...
...not too far from the last place is right behind the main mosque.
You have this gate with the mosque on the back.
The next stop is the Peranakan houses in the Joo Chiat neighborhood.
They're super colorful and one next to the other.